[Applause]
it was the most chaotic we get in
Parliament's continuing failure to come
to grips with the public's vote to leave
the EU so the noes have it
the noes have it i profoundly regret the
decision that this house has taken
tonight the Prime Minister's run down
the clock and the clock has been run out
on her MPs voted against the Prime
Minister's deal then voted against
leaving without a deal before voting to
delay brexit I've been reporting from
this place for more than 30 years and
I've never seen anything like it
our nation is facing its most important
decision for half a century and yet it
seems government and Parliament are
unable or incapable of making up their
minds what to do about it much to the
annoyance of the people politics is in
meltdown of course Europe has always
divided politicians and parties like
nothing else in the 1970s the Labour
Prime Minister Harold Wilson got himself
out of a tricky corner by handing the
decision of whether to stay in the
European community to the public with a
referendum David Cameron tried the same
thing with less certainty and lost I do
not think it would be right for me to
try to be the captain that steers our
country to its next destination Theresa
May took on the job and decided to try
and take the country out of the EU with
as little input from MPs as possible as
we leave the European Union we will
forge a bold new positive role for
ourselves in the world but she was
thwarted by the Supreme Court which
ruled against the government and in
favour of a businesswoman named Gina
Miller no government can expect to be
unanswerable or unchallenged Parliament
alone is sovereign
MPs now had the right to approve the
deal to leave but they couldn't agree on
what deal they wanted the Prime Minister
called an election in the hope of
strengthening her hand but she lost her
majority in a hung parliament she had to
strike a deal with the DUP to stay in
power
but the Northern Irish unionists haven't
backed the government on brexit nor have
a significant number of Conservative MPs
mainly associated with the European
research group led by Jacob Riis MOG if
we went ahead and held the votes
tomorrow the deal would be rejected
missus may put off the moment of truth
by repeatedly delaying a meaningful vote
the parliamentary party does have
confidence and she had to fight off an
attempt by some of her own MPs to kick
her out in a vote of no confidence in
her leadership with the clock counting
down to brexit day mrs. Mae had to call
the meaningful vote the eyes to the
right 202 the nose to the left
432 she lost by 230 the biggest defeat
inflicted by MPs for at least a hundred
years having failed to sacker
conservative MPs then backed her in a
commons confidence vote to avoid having
a general election and then mrs. Mae
lost again by 149 this time nose to the
left 391 so the noes have it
the noes have it I love but she's still
here and is planning to ask MPs tobacker
in yet another meaningful vote next week
this is not how British politics used to
work when a prime minister couldn't get
laws passed let alone deliver a central
piece of their policy agenda they packed
their bags and resigned but these are
not normal times there's no precedent
for what's happening now back in the
1970s sonny jim callaghan's government
fell six days after losing a series of
votes in the Commons because labour no
longer had a majority Callaghan lost the
vote of no-confidence by one vote and a
general election followed good morning
prime minister a sad day in 1990
Conservative MPs were able to oust
Margaret Thatcher as party leader and
Prime
stur John major followed and was
defeated over Europe this time by his
own Euroskeptic rebels but he was able
to face them down rule changes since
then prevent mrs. maid from taking the
same way out
she can't resign the leadership and
stand again in spite of enduring the
largest rebellion ever by conservative
MPs nor can she call a snap election
because the fixed term Parliament act
now applies no Prime Minister at odds
with their own MPs has ever had fewer
options this is the time for this house
not just this government or indeed this
Prime Minister but for this house to
give a lead even when 139 Labour MPs
rebelled over Iraq Tony Blair had enough
support across the Commons to win the
vote outright David Cameron was forced
to rule out taking military action in
Syria after MPs voted to reject his
plans his authority was greatly
diminished but he left it at that
Theresa May can't walk away on brexit
two and a half years on all eyes are on
Westminster because nobody knows where
we're heading there's still no sign of
agreement instead it seems likely that
negotiations will be extended and the
fundamental problems remain the same
Teresa may's plan is unpopular her party
is divided so is Parliament and the
country these divisions have broken the
rules that govern us until and unless
that can be resolved the big question
mark there hang over whether our
political system is fit for the
challenges we face Adam Bolton Sky News
Westminster